did you guys see the homer story with
joe rogan
did you see that story homer gets
canceled meets joe rogan a new simpsons
episode this is a new york post story
the simpsons
is dividing critics after spoofing
controversial podcast host joe rogan 54
in a brand new episode
satirizing
cancel culture in the divisive season 33
episode 14 titled you won't believe what
this episode is about act 3 will shock
you homework
is erroneously blamed for leaving the
family dog named santa little helper
in a hot car resulting in him getting
publicly shamed newsweek reported things
really go off the rails when the
simpsons
patriarch tries to apologize and
inadvertently knocks reverend
lovejoy out of the church window videos
of the fiasco subsequently go viral on
social media causing homer to lose his
job and become ostracized by his family
and friends co-workers eventually the
donut gobbler meets up with joe rogan
paul ganger the commentators never
explicitly mentioned by name but he is
represented by a generic right-wing
podcast host
who is the only one willing to meet with
homer following his cancellation
needless to say the gap ring hollow with
many critics with screen uh rant deeming
it's bizarrely misguided and
self-contradictory particularly
problematic per side with the fact that
homer was under
uh undeserving of his ex communication
presumably unlikely many so-called
victims of cancer culture so
what do you think about this by the way
does that even look like joe rogan does
he look like kind of joe little bit yeah
i like how they just said we're not
going to name him right wing [ __ ] okay
right
how shall we draw him let's draw him
like this and we won't name him
yeah yeah the the other day they uh uh
they called russell brand a right-wing
podcast can you imagine calling russell
brand right wing republican podcast but
apparently now joe rogan is a couple of
the guys shared a video was true it went
viral on on twitter about the times joe
has said things that has nothing to do
with being right-wing the only thing
he's doing is he's questioning things
right i think he said one time you know
barack obama's the best president of our
generation yeah right-wing guy would
never say that they would probably say
something he would vote for bernie he
would vote for bernie he said a bunch of
different things but uh such [ __ ]
how they portray him as being right-wing
just because he says things that are
contradictory to the narrative that is
being spoken out there it's absolutely
true look he's he
he just has interesting people on and
you know
asks questions good questions you've
been on rogan how many times yeah a
dozen or so just a dozen times
no big deal mike baker cia yeah yeah but
it's it's he's he's just he's just
curious he's curious about everything
right but god forbid you should you know
have someone say something on your show
that somebody else doesn't agree with i
don't the one thing about self-righteous
people is i don't know how they they're
so [ __ ] dry they have there's no
sense of humor right i mean who the [ __ ]
takes exception to a simpsons episode i
mean how does that work
so
anyway meanwhile meanwhile joe keeps
winning
because all this you do you're all just
helping them win the mainstream media
doesn't even know it they're officially
joe rogan's best publicist and the great
news is he has to pay them
nothing they're doing it for free
oh by the way all this publicity they're
doing do you realize
if you if you were to put a dollar
amount
of how much the media's [ __ ] talking of
him making videos saying stuff how many
billions of views it got joe and if you
were to put a dollar amount on it i'm
gonna speculate on what that dollar
amount is if joe was running for office
and he wanted to buy this viewership
it's probably going to cost him 300
million dollars so mainstream media just
brought joe rogan 300 million dollars of
free publicity by the way joe needs to
say thank you to my favorite publicist
by the way this is not this is not new
the same thing happened with rush
limbaugh you may remember that there is
a small coterie of democrat congressmen
that tried to pass what they called the
hush rush act
and he was talking about equal time and
that led rush on this big campaign where
it was i am equal time and it actually
propelled rush from the consortium of am
talk into the whole eib network and so
it actually was jet fuel on russia's
trajectory and we see it again 20 years
later yep and by the way
all the news of rogan getting canceled
you don't hear that as much anymore
right this reminds me of kind of what
jordan peterson said he was sitting in
mike baker's seat right there he said
listen the hardest part
to do
is
deal with it when it's at its worst when
things are the heat is on you if you
could stick it out
you'll be sitting pretty on the other
side now
you know everything that happened with
our friends at spotify and
um rumble offered him 100 million bucks
yeah where's that now yeah i think he'll
survive the worst of it neil young put
himself back on spotify as it turns out
went back yeah he went back and as did i
think everyone else i'd love to see the
neil young on joe rogan podcast coming
soon
oh by the way that would be that would
be
if there's a guy that could pull it off
he could pull it off to to do something
like that if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you